Cheryl can you just ask how are you
feeling
what's it really no
the defendant has not acknowledged his
responsibility for Olivia's death and so
has demonstrated no remorse
his failure to come into court is
perhaps further evidence of that on
count one for the murder of Olivia Pratt
Corbell the sentence will be life
imprisonment
the minimum term will be 42 years less
the time the defendant has already spent
on remand
on count two the attempted murder of
Joseph knee the sentence is life
imprisonment with a minimum term of 22
years
on count 3 wounding Cheryl Corbell with
intent to do Grievous bodily harm to
another the sentence is 10 years
imprisonment
on counts four and five the Firearms
offenses the sentence is 18 years
imprisonment on each it is plain that
Olivia was a lovely little girl who
cared for others and brightened the
lives of her family and friends
they have suffered an unimaginable loss
which they must carry for the rest of
their lives
nothing I say or do today will ease that
but they should know that they have my
sympathy
Olivia was just beautiful with their
long brown hair
and big brown eyes everyone adored here
she was the baby off of our family on my
little love my shadow
now everything we do and everywhere we
go was a constant reminder that if she
is not there with us all our promise for
their future so cruelly taken away
we can now draw a line onto seven months
of agonize and torment that we had to
we have had to endure at the hands of
Cashman
we welcome the sentence given but what I
can say is that my family and I have
already started our life sentence having
to spend the rest of our lives without
Olivia our greatest hope is for this
conviction to lead to more guns and
especially those used in the Mesa of
Olivia
to be handed into the police so there
are no other families must go through
this tragedy lastly I would like to say
Olivia Pratt Corbell died a scared
nine-year-old and we hope Cashman is
haunted by this knowledge for the rest
of his life